[Music]
just who in the hell do you think you
are
was awesome
ah
he's so chewed
what's that he says welcome to the
frickin guardians of the galaxy only he
didn't use frickin
oh look out oh wow I tried guys
when I hear the trumpet sound
I'm on a ride right out of the craft
ain't no grave can hold my
body down the dad I've taken come on the
surgical spiral we'll look
owning Italy guys
and come in that
pirates life there ain't no brain hello
my buddy Amazing Grace how sweet the
sound bass say
I
my Cree real or you want to know don't
you why they keep coming here to earth
where are the others ones you're hiding
I don't sell out friends you'll weld is
dying
no the miss Prime
[Music]
do you seek Redemption
my Lakers are a queue
while you're watching the game they are
watching the bay
welcome to Baywatch few people are
lifeguards not police you people
you don't get to say that you're just 10
right oh come on brother why does she
look like she's running somehow you see
you two ready to do this
Haley whoa whoa were you wearing freedom
that's desecration Dominic Toretto just
went rogue you're gonna turn your back
on family
I'm taking you down so write out where I
got if you're gonna catch da you gonna
need a little help you want to tell me
why you just put me in a room with this
criminal you don't seem that tight
t-shirts cut off the circulation heal
Brian you should get bigger sighs you
guys are gonna work together love to
nope at five miles away
[Music]
and just don't give up today
Oh
I didn't want to think swimming I got
you roller hey guys it's a girl
congratulations
have any idea who the father is shut up
what's xxx time alright let's go
three two one this is dr. David Jordan
our mission is to intercept a research
pod from Mars sixteen steps to fix the
shower I'm an astronaut not a gym
teacher this is the first capsule ever
to come back from the clinic we have
visual confirmation I said this could be
a major scientific breakthrough come on
come on come on come on whoa Q Instagram
we're looking at the first proof of life
beyond a lowering oxygen more carbon
dioxide that's beautiful
you finally a daddy it's gonna be a big
custody battle over this one ie trophy
washing pectoris no we're gonna keep it
up here gonna study we're safe
you can't fastest-growing every single
cell is a muscle cell I don't have cell
muscle
well brain how smart is this thing these
creatures wiped out Mars millions of
years ago if we let it get to earth well
risk all human life let's kill the thing
good night moon good night room good
night cow jumping over the moon
goodnight light red blue
what is the primal instinct of any
life-form to survivor goodnight stars
we've lost all communication goodnight
there look at the atmosphere in 39
minutes my branching but it could
goodnight always do this everywhere
oh my a go
[Music]
[Music]
yes secure
actually I was just leaving another
loose
accept the diagnosis then you will see
it's wonderful here
for wellness where did our
[Music]
it did not save your life they stole it
are you tired of not feeling well take
the cure and take back your life
side effects include sins you drylands
drowsiness weight loss nausea skin
eruptions anxiety severe hallucinations
unconsciousness
insanity Southwind elation
love your sweet
in 12 days take the cure radar
[Music]
yeah
rough night rough night John wick
Chapter two wicked are in theatres
Friday don't push this but because that
will set off the bomb immediately and
we'll all be dead
[Music]